[Music]  Billy Bobby Brown and Jacob Sartorius  have called it quits the 14 year old  stranger things star and her 15 year old  musician boyfriend announced the news on  their Instagram stories quote the  decision with Jacob and I was completely  mutual we are both happy and remaining  friends the former couple made it  official on social media in January and  haven't shied away from a little online  PDA on Browns birthday in February  Sartorius called her the funniest most  caring person in a sweet tweet Jenga to  admire and in March  Sartorius shared this video of the duo  jamming out together the following month  the actress shared this pic of her then  beau giving her a piggyback ride and in  May the hit me back singer posted a pic  of the pair at the beach along with the  caption all right but even better with  you  [Music]